i'm not insinuating i'm just saying i'm
speaking from experience because i don't
want to hear the excuse of oh because
you're a woman you gotta go in that
environment and that's a certain way
rubbish because of your color rubbish
because of your sex rubbish because of
the pain rubbish because i've done it
and it's the norm i've done it so all
women need to do if you want to get paid
more the same way how you can speak up
and say i'm a woman this and that
speaker must say excuse me but i'm doing
pay rise can i have my money this is how
hard i've worked this is what i deserve
and this is what my contract says now
that's what i'm saying that now you can
do that but it hasn't always been like
that no i'm older than you i'm 53 i'm
retired so you can't say now you can do
that because i've been doing it okay but
you can't this is what i mean you can't
ignore the history okay but before i'm
history
i'm the history
i am the
i am retired i am your history so you
can't tell me to forget about the
history
and before my history my mother done the
same job